[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Hanna
Zimmermann und Christian Siebers guten
Abend ihnen wir beginnen mit nicht
weniger als der Zukunft der Arbeit das
ist deshalb so extrem wichtig und
interessant weil diese Zukunft gerade
neu bestimmt wird und die Arbeitswelt so
wie wir sie bislang kannten danach kaum
wieder zu erkennen sein wird heute sind
die aktuellen Zahlen vom Arbeitsmarkt
bekommen die Arbeitslosigkeit ist im
Juli um 0,2% Punkte gestiegen auf 5,7
Prozent zur Sommerpause üblich und weit
weniger trübe als die gesamtaussichten
der Wirtschaft in vielen Branchen
schlägt der Mangel an Fachkräften immer
deutlicher zu gleichzeitig wachsen die
Erwartungen vier Tage Woche keine
Überstunden Homeoffice es gab Zeiten da
konnten jobbewerber mit solchen
Ansprüchen gleich nach Hause gehen diese
Zeiten sind vorbei wie Isabella zeigt
in Joachim Seibert Softwareunternehmen
dürfen die Mitarbeiter selbst bestimmen
wie viele Stunden sie pro Woche arbeiten
wann sie anfangen und ob im Büro oder zu
Hause kein Problem meint der Chef alle
sind in Teams organisiert das Gehalt
wird angepasst und hauptsache der Output
stimmt wir müssen uns darauf einstellen
was der Markt hergibt und wenn die Leute
sagen ich komme aber nur wenn ich 30
Stunden arbeiten darf dann habe ich
keine Wahl dann muss ich mich darauf
einlassen und dann hilft es auch nicht
zu sagen ist ärgert mich oder so sondern
ich muss es einfach hinnehmen und sagen
ich akzeptiere so wie es ist und mache
das Beste draus und schlafe nur Umgebung
in der das gut funktionieren kann
Arbeitgeber müssen viel bieten in Zeiten
des Fachkräftemangels der immer
dramatischer wird weil die Bevölkerung
schrumpft nach Prognosen wird die Zahl
der Erwerbstätigen von der Zeit 46
Millionen Menschen bis 2016 auf 28
Millionen sinken übersetzt in
Arbeitszeit fehlen mindestens 4,2
Milliarden Arbeitsstunden jährlich
eine Verkürzung der Arbeitszeit ginge
daher in die falsche Richtung so
Experten Mehrarbeit sei hingegen nötig
weil sonst die Menge der produzierten
Waren und Dienstleistungen noch mehr
zurückgehe der Einzelne wird das
zunächst dadurch merken dass gewisse
Leistungen nicht mehr zur Verfügung
stehen weil das Restaurant vielleicht
nur noch zweimal die Woche aufmacht oder
Kindergärten keine neuen Kinder mehr
aufnehmen können alle diese Dinge die
aus einem Arbeitskräftemangel heraus
resultieren können werden sicherlich
zunehmen in der nächsten Zeit und das
wird eben dazu führen dass wir einen
starken
Wohlstandsverlust bemerken doch mehr
arbeiten geht nicht immer zum Beispiel
wenn berufstätige Eltern werden und
flexibel arbeiten müssen nicht weniger
Leistung heißen das sagen wiederum
andere Experten
es wird selbstbestimmbare Arbeitszeiten
geben es wird flexiblere Arbeitszeiten
geben die x-tage-woche also die
wahlarbeitszeit die über den
Lebensverlauf auch zu ändern ist die
wird die Zukunft sein denn damit
steigert sich wirklich die Zufriedenheit
der Beschäftigten und damit am Ende auch
die Leistung und Produktivität wenn
Betriebe mehr Aufgaben digitalisieren
würden könne das die wegfallenden
Arbeitsstunden kompensieren sagen manche
die fachkräftekrise sei sogar eine
Chance für etwas ganz Neues glaubt der
Vorstandsvorsitzende vom Jobportal
StepStone
oft sind der Krisen der beste
Katalysator dafür dass man mal wirklich
etwas verändert viele Betriebe stellen
sich die Frage wie schaffe ich es die
gleiche Leistung oder sogar mehr
Leistung mit weniger Mitarbeitern
hinzubekommen und das bringt dann
Innovation und das bringt Fortschritt
und damit auch mehr Wohlstand bei
Joachim Seibert hat das geklappt sein
Unternehmen wächst trotz des
Fachkräftemangels und flexibler
Arbeitszeiten
die Chefin der Bundesagentur für Arbeit
ist bei uns Andrea Nahles
guten Abend Herr Sievers reden wir über
die Zukunft der Arbeit beginnen wir aber
ganz aktuell vielleicht heute
Arbeitsmarkt zahlen die wirtschaftlichen
Aussichten sind deutlich drüber als die
Situation bei der Arbeitslosigkeit heißt
das da entkoppelt sich etwas Konjunktur
und Arbeitsmarkt und auch ein
Wirtschaftseinbruch führt eben nicht
automatisch zu einer dramatisch höheren
Arbeitslosigkeit ja nach drei Monaten
Null wachsen was wir jetzt hatten hat
hält sich der Arbeitsmarkt tatsächlich
gut und deswegen sage ich ja es gibt
eine Entkopplung denn das eigentliche
zugrunde liegende dominante Thema ist
die demografische Entwicklung der
Fachkräftemangel ist einfach noch
stärker als der Einbruch im
wirtschaftlichen Bereich jetzt haben sie
es gerade selbst schon angekündigt
angesprochen sie haben heute gesagt
Arbeitskräfte Nachfrage die ist
weiterhin zurückhaltend andererseits
gibt es eben das was sie gerade sagten
es Stöhnen ganze Branchen unter Lärm mit
dem auf der Mangel wie passt denn das
zusammen
naja also es ist wenn wir sagen
zurückhaltend dann kommen wir von sehr
hohem Niveau das ist immer noch deutlich
mehr als in den letzten Jahren das heißt
wir merken dass es ein Schwenken gibt
auf die wirtschaftliche konjunkturelle
Lage aber insgesamt haben wir noch ein
sehr hohes Niveau und über alles hinweg
ist der Fachkräftebedarf in Deutschland
immer noch sehr hoch gut da kommt auch
noch zusätzlich einiges auf uns zu
Stichwort demografische Lücke wenn wir
uns mal so ein bisschen die Zukunft
anschauen wird dann aus ihrem Haus aus
der Bundesagentur für Arbeit in Zukunft
so eine Art Headhunter Büro das Hände
Ringen Fachkräfte sucht
ja also wir sind momentan in der
Transformation zum Beispiel mit sowas
wie arbeitsmarktdrehscheiben unterwegs
wenn wir merken dass in Unternehmen
Arbeitsplätze abgibt Leute entlassen
muss dann wird gar keine
Arbeitslosigkeit wenn es nach uns geht
entstehen sondern wir suchen dann schon
in der Region arbeitsmarktträger
Arbeitgeber die dringend Fachkräfte
suchen das ist eigentlich die
Arbeitsmarktpolitik wie wir sie
verstehen als transformationsbegleitung
eigentlich das hat auch unsere Rolle
auch in der Arbeitsmarktpolitik deutlich
verändert in den letzten Jahren von
alles das haben wir im Film gerade
gesehen die einen in Deutschland sagen
wir verlieren Wohlstand wenn wir nicht
mehr arbeiten und die anderen die sagen
wir verlieren Lebensqualität wenn wir
mehr arbeiten haben aus ihrer Sicht
beide irgendwie recht
ja ich würde mir mal angucken wann
wollen und wie wollen die Leute arbeiten
ich kann es von mir selber sagen als ich
noch keine Tochter hatte da war mir das
egal mit der Arbeitszeit als ich sie
dann hatte war es mir gar nicht egal da
muss ich gucken wie ich das mit dem
Familienleben unter Betreuung der
Tochter hinbekomme und dann wenn die
Kinder aus dem Haus sind dann geht
vielleicht wieder mehr und wenn man
älter wird über 60 dann ist man gerne
noch dabei aber vielleicht nicht mehr
ganz mit den Überstunden konnten wie man
es vielleicht früher geschafft hat also
war für ich plädiere ist sich die
Lebensphasen anzugucken einfach eine
Lebens Phasen bezogene Arbeitszeit und
Arbeitsmarktpolitik zu machen das wäre
etwas was wir glauben erfolgreich sein
könnte wer glaubt in dieser Welt mit
einer 4 Tage Woche durchzukommen der
glaubt auch dass man im Fußball nach 80
Minuten in die Kabine gehen kann guter
Spruch
also noch mal ähm ich bin nicht
ein
möglichst noch polarisierend
einzumischen ich kann nur darauf
hinweisen was wir beobachten wir haben
Leute die auch nach dem Eintritt ins
Rentenalter noch freiwillig
weiterarbeiten wir haben eine Frauen
Erwerbsbeteiligung die gut ist aber die
Frauen arbeiten im Verhältnis zu anderen
europäischen Ländern halt wesentlich
weniger Arbeitsstunden da genau
hinzugucken wie kann man denn
tatsächlich auf die individuellen
Bedürfnisse der Leute besser eingehen
bringt glaube ich unterm Strich ein Teil
der Lösung dieses Problems der Spruch
war übrigens von Markus Söder dann
verstehe ich sie richtig wir brauchen
viel viel mehr Flexibilität das wäre ja
dann wenn wenn wenn ihr ihr Muster am
Ende tatsächlich ziehen sollte so etwas
wie für jeden der maßgeschneiderte
Arbeitsplatz und dann auch jeweils immer
noch nach Lebensalter naja aber wissen
Sie wir haben so viele digitale
Möglichkeiten heute ich habe neulichen
Betriebe in Regensburg besucht die tun
auch in einem Industriebetrieb die
Schichten schon digital selber planen
die Mitarbeiterinnen und Mitarbeiter da
geht heute viel mehr auch mit
technischen Hilfsmitteln und mit gutem
Willen der arbeitgebermarkt den wir bei
Jahrzehnte haben hat sich in den
ArbeitnehmerInnen und Arbeitnehmermarkt
verwandelt da muss man ein Stück weit
drauf eingehen tatsächlich auf die
individuellen Bedürfnisse der Menschen
sagt Andrea Nahles die Chefin der
Bundesagentur für Arbeit von alles
vielen Dank
und das Interview haben wir aus Termin
Gründen kurz vor dieser Sendung
aufgezeichnet
das ist die klassische Postkartenansicht
bei der alle sofort wissen dass ist
Moskau aber im Hintergrund deutet es
sich schon an was eben auch moskau ist 5
km entfernt vom Kreml das hier ein
glitzerndes Hochhausviertel mit ein paar
der höchsten Gebäude Europas Sitz von
Banken Oligarchen Ministerien so
wirklich auseinander zu halten sind die
ja nicht immer auf jeden Fall der Stolz
von Russlands macht Elite und das Geld
Zentrum des Landes Moskau city
heute wieder Ziel eines drohnenangriffs
es war der zweite innerhalb von drei
Tagen ein Berater des ukrainischen
Präsidenten sagt dazu Moskau müsse mit
weiteren solcher Angriffe rechnen und
mit Zitat mehr Krieg für begabberichtet
das Ministerium für Industrie und Handel
das Ministerium für digitale Entwicklung
die Liste der Mieter von IQ water ist
lang und bedeutsam sie könnte einen
Hinweis darauf geben wieso der Turm zum
zweiten Mal binnen weniger Tage Ziel
einer drohnenattacke wurde
beängstigend die Tatsache dass alles
ungestraft geschieht dass die jeden
Moment hier rein fliegen können ist
gruselig
heute wurde Moskau City getroffen morgen
wird es eine Antwort gegen KF geben dann
wieder eine Antwort gegen Moskau und so
weiter ich denke es sollte
Friedensgespräche geben
Wohlstand Fortschritt Modernität die
Drohnen haben die schillernde Fassade
der russischen Hauptstadt durchbrochen
die öffentliche Agenda des Präsidenten
bleibt davon unerschüttert kein Wort zu
den Angriffen stattdessen Lob für die
Arbeit des Föderationsrates kurz vor der
Sommerpause
generell war die Arbeit natürlich sehr
stressig aber es wurden effektive
Entscheidungen getroffen rechtzeitig
dazu gehört auch dass das Parlament
höhere Strafen für Kriegsdienst
Verweigerer beschlossen hat und das
Alter für den Wehrdienst angehoben wird
so können mehr Russen eingezogen werden
ohne dass eine neue unpopuläre
mobilisierungswelle ausgerufen werden
muss
möglichst geräuschlos managt die
russische Politik den Krieg doch die
Drohnen Kratzen am Gefühl der
Unverwundbarkeit das muss heute selbst
der kremmelsprecher zugeben
ich habe ihnen gestern schon gesagt dass
nur die Militärs dies aus Expertensicht
kommentieren können tatsächlich besteht
eine Gefahr sie ist offensichtlich aber
es werden Maßnahmen ergriffen
die Drohnenangriffe auf die Hauptstadt
sie häufen sich
ihr Sinn liege weniger im militärischen
als im psychologischen meint der
kriegsjournalist Sergey Ausländer
sehr viele Menschen in Russland
insbesondere in Moskau haben nicht das
Gefühl dass es einen Krieg gibt sie
nehmen den Krieg als eine Art
Auslandseinsatz war wie ein Krieg in
Afghanistan der irgendwo weit entfernt
stattfindet
doch mit jeder drohnenattacke auf Moskau
trinkt der Krieg tiefer in die russische
Realität ein denn auf das was in der
Hauptstadt passiert schaut jeder im Land
und jetzt schauen wir auf einen ersten
Nachrichtenüberblick heute mit Johanna
nach dem Putsch im Niger hat das
Auswärtige Amt eine Reisewarnung für das
westafrikanische Land ausgesprochen und
deutsche Staatsangehörige zur Ausreise
aufgerufen Frankreich brachte am Abend
mit einem ersten evakuierungsflug nach
eigenen Angaben mehr als 260 Menschen
aus dem Land die französische Regierung
hatte auch anderen EU-Bürgern Angeboten
mitzufliegen das Auswärtige Amt Ried
dazu diese Möglichkeit zu nutzen
genau zehn Jahre nach Einführung des
Rechtsanspruchs auf einen Kita-Platz für
Kinder ab einem Jahr gibt es noch immer
deutlich zu wenig Betreuungsplätze in
Deutschland laut dem Institut der
deutschen Wirtschaft gab es 2022 knapp
266.000 Plätze zu wenig damit sei die
Betreuungslücke sogar gewachsen 2014
fehlten
187.000 die Situation könnte sich laut
dem IW in diesem Jahr sogar noch
verschärfen grund sei der wachsende
Bedarf durch geflüchtete Kinder aus der
Ukraine
die im Bundestag vertretenden Parteien
haben in diesem Jahr deutlich mehr groß
Spenden von einzelpersonenunternehmen
und Verbänden erhalten in den ersten
sieben Monaten bekamen die Parteien bis
auf die linke demnach rund 1,18
Millionen Euro und damit mehr als
doppelt so viel wie im Vorjahreszeitraum
auf Platz 1 der Empfänger liegt die CDU
mit rund 316.000 € auf Platz zwei die
AFD mit rund
65000 dann folgen die FDP die Grünen die
SPD und die CSU
die Militär herunter in Myanmar hat
angekündigt die ehemalige de
facto-regierungschefin
im Zuge einer Massen Amnestie teilweise
zu begnadigen staatlichen Medien zufolge
soll die Haftstrafe der
Friedensnobelpreisträgerin reduziert
werden und zwar von 33 auf 27 Jahre
Experten werteten diesen Schritten nicht
als Kurswechsel der runter
war 2021 im Zuge eines Militärputsches
entmachtet und festgenommen worden
wer eine erbitterte Diskussion in seinem
E-Mail-Postfach finden will muss nur im
Fernsehen anfangen zu sagen guten Abend
liebe ZuschauerInnen das Gendern ist
aktuelles Schlachtfeld um die deutsche
Sprache vor exakt 25 Jahren gab es
ähnliches es ging da etwa um den Kuss
neu mit Doppel s den Spaß weiterhin mit
scharfem s eine große Rechtschreibreform
sollte alles einfacher machen
der Kaiser sollte im Boot fahren es
begann ein großer Streit Luisa
wie ist es richtig wir fragen nach in
der Stuttgarter Stadtbibliothek also
schreiben
stimmt
ihr würdet so schreiben
25 Jahre ist es her das mit der
Rechtschreibreform das Schreiben
leichter werden soll
und fahren wird jetzt getrennt Fluss mit
Doppel S und Gämse mit ä geschrieben
neue Regeln die auf viel Widerspruch
stoßen Günther Grass weigert sich lässt
seine Werke drucken wie gehabt andere
finden das albern mir ist die
Rechthaberei der Gegner der
rechtschreiber-reform in den letzten
Monaten ziemlich auf den Geist gegangen
manche Regeln setzen sich einfach nicht
durch weil sich Sprache mit der
Gesellschaft entwickelt
beschreiben Alter mit verbindet sich ein
Gefühl mit dem Zelt also Schrift ist ja
mehr als dass ich nur irgendwas
dekodieren kann in den 90ern tobt ein
Kulturkampf um FFF und Doppel P heute
wird wieder gestritten
ja ja ist klar 200 Anfragen bekommt der
Rat für deutsche Rechtschreibung
monatlich zum Gendern viele davon
hasserfüllt schüler:innen oder Schüler
wenn es dazu führt dass mehr Leute sich
angesprochen fühlen oder man sich
gerechte behandelt fühlt finde ich warum
nicht Wichtigeres zu tun als dass wir
uns jetzt zum des Sternchen kümmern wenn
man einheitliche Regel hat dann hat sich
die Diskussion relativ schnell erledigt
aber der Rat findet sich ins Regelwerk
sollen die genderzeichen nicht gelten
als grammatikalisch falsch gleichzeitig
betont der Rat in einer Erklärung dass
allen mit geschlechtergerechter Sprache
begegnet werden soll das war ein hartes
Ringen und da sind schon konträre
Positionen aufeinander geprallt die eben
nur durch einen Kompromiss auch
aufgefangen werden konnte so laut tobt
der Kampf ums Sternchen dass die meisten
Experten die wir fragen sich nicht vor
die Kamera trauen Renata stepaniak hat
einen Vorschlag und weckt jedes Wort ab
möglich wäre eine kannregel mit einem
ausgewählten wortbinnen zeichnen jüngste
Positionierung bietet jedoch immer noch
keine normgerechte Lösung genau für eine
geschlechtergerechte Sprache der
Philologenverband lehnt die
genderzeichen ab fordert Einheitlichkeit
mir geht es vor allem darum dass der
Erwerb der deutschen Sprache die
Lesbarkeit und die Verständlichkeit für
Schülerinnen und Schüler gewährleistet
wird sie sollten es einheitlich lernen
können ob es doch mal mehr Möglichkeiten
geben wird ist offen der Rat will das
Gendern weiter beobachten die
gesellschaftliche Debatte wird ihn dazu
zwingen
und im heute journal Update nachher dazu
noch einige Fragen an einen
Sprachwissenschaftler
können Sie sich noch an uniper erinnern
ja das ist der Düsseldorfer Energieriese
der vergangenen Jahr die wohl größte
Pleite der bundesdeutschen Geschichte
hingelegt hätte wenn er nicht mit
Milliarden an Steuergeldern gerettet
worden wäre fett im Russlandgeschäft war
das Unternehmen mit Beginn des Krieges
gegen die Ukraine ins Wanken geraten
aber als Deutschlands größter Gashändler
eben auch to big to fail die aktuellen
Unternehmenszahlen gerade mal acht
Monate später scheinen Juniper selbst
etwas peinlich zu sein es gibt nämlich
einen Milliarden Gewinn direkt nach dem
beinahe Zusammenbruch das beste Ergebnis
der Unternehmensgeschichte Ralf Goldmann
es waren unruhige Zeiten in den
vergangenen Monaten hier im Handelsraum
des Energiekonzerns Juniper in
Düsseldorf als Russland kein billiges
Gas mehr lieferte da mussten sie teuer
nachkaufen um ihre eigenen
Lieferverpflichtungen erfüllen zu können
so teuer dass der Konzern fast pleite
ging wäre da nicht der Staat mit 30
Milliarden Euro in die breche gesprungen
uniper sein systemrelevant der Kraftakt
des Staates alternativlos so der Kanzler
damals diesen großen Kraftakt stemmen
wir das haben wir heute entschieden am
Vormittag stellte sich ein strahlendes
Management vor die Kameras und
verkündete eine Nettogewinn von 2,5
Milliarden Euro im ersten Halbjahr und
von den 30 Milliarden benötigte Unicorn
noch nicht einmal die Hälfte der neue
Vorstand sprach von einem Turnaround
uniper sei zurück die Ergebnisse geben
der uns die Kraft und das
Selbstvertrauen wieder voll durchstarten
jetzt ist genau der richtige Moment für
einen Neustart die Gründe für die
Erholung sind vielfältig einerseits
liefern jetzt andere Länder anstelle von
Russland mehr Gas nach Deutschland auch
an die neuen Flüssiggas Terminals die
eilig an den Küsten gebaut worden sind
dadurch sind die Gasspeicher gut gefüllt
andererseits ist der Verbrauch insgesamt
zurückgegangen auch wegen des relativ
milden Wetters am Jahresanfang und die
Nachfrage in Asien Schwäche das alles
habe auch Juniper geholfen sagt
Energieexperte Tobias Federico der
Einstieg des Staates sei gut gewesen für
die gesamte Energiewirtschaft dieses
Jahr sehen die Zahlen von uniper
deutlich besser aus als es letztes Jahr
überhaupt erwartet wurde falls sich der
Erdgasmarkt erholt hat also insofern war
das gut und es scheint auch ein ganz
gutes Geschäft für den Bund gewesen zu
sein das zeigt sich am Aktienkurs von
über 40 € stürzte das Papier auf zwei
Euro 20 der Bund übernahm die Anteile
für 1,70 € heutiger Wert 5,90 €. der
Bund könnte also theoretisch schon jetzt
mit Gewinn verkaufen wann das passiert
ist aber völlig offen ein Ministerium
Sprecher teilte auf zdf-anfrage nur mit
das Bundesministerium der Finanzen nimmt
die wirtschaftliche Entwicklung des
Unternehmens als positives Zeichen zu
Kenntnis
möglich ist dass der Bund nach und nach
Anteile an private Investoren abgibt wir
werden diesen Winter wahrscheinlich noch
etwas nervös werden aber danach
beruhigen sich die Energiemärkte und
dann kann es durchaus sein dass Juniper
dann doch tatsächlich sehr ertragreich
sein wird in der Zukunft das Management
plant bereits jetzt neue Investitionen
um den Konzern umzubauen und schon 2014
CO2-neutral zu machen 10 Jahre früher
als geplant und sie gaben ein
Versprechen man brauche mit Sicherheit
keine weiteren Staatshilfen mehr
da kann einem schwindelig werden kommt
so fassen dieser Phoenix aus der Asche
Aufstiege Valerie guten Abend gerade
noch 19 Milliarden miese in 2022 jetzt
plötzlich Milliarden Profit wie genau
war das möglich
nun das liegt vor allem am inzwischen
wieder günstigeren Gas davon konnte
uniper nämlich gleich doppelt
profitieren zum einen mit geschickten
absicherungsgeschäften die dazu führen
dass Juniper viel Gas zu einem günstigen
Preis einkaufen es aber zu einem höheren
Preis verkaufen konnte denn Juniper hat
langlaufende Verträge mit Kunden wie den
Stadtwerken und hatte da einen weit
höheren Preis vereinbart ja und dann
kommt noch ein bilanzieller Effekt hinzu
Juniper musste wegen der Krise am
Gasmarkt hohe Rückstellungen bilden also
sozusagen als Notgroschen da sich die
Lage am Gasmarkt entspannt hat kann
Juniper dieses Geld in der Bilanz wieder
auflösen und das wirkt sich jetzt
entsprechend positiv auf der Habenseite
aus ja positiv für Juniper Industrie und
private Haushalte allerdings die 16 Jahr
weiter unter hohen Strom und Gaspreisen
der Versorger macht auf der anderen
Seite Milliarden Gewinn und ist damit ja
nicht alleine können wir alle denn
erwarten dass die Energiepreise auch für
uns dann wieder runtergehen
also grundsätzlich ist ja wieder etwas
Ruhe eingekehrt in den Gasmarkt die
Preise sind gesunken und mit
Verzögerungen sollte sich das auch auf
die Preise beim Endverbraucher
niederschlagen
Verbraucherschützer sagen jetzt wäre ein
guter Zeitpunkt über einen Wechsel
nachzudenken denn wer jetzt einen neuen
Vertrag abschließt der braucht gar keine
gaspreisbremse mehr ein kalter Winter
aber der könnte die Preise wieder
steigen lassen dann sagen wir herzlichen
Dank an Valerie an der Börse in
Frankfurt
und sagen hier nochmal Hannah ja und da
bleiben wir beim Thema Energie
Bundeswirtschaftsminister Harbeck und
die EU-Kommission haben sich auf
Leitplanken für die staatliche Förderung
von neuen Wasserstoff und Gaskraftwerken
geeinigt diese sollen unter anderem
Kohlekraftwerke ersetzen und die
Stromproduktion CO2-neutral machen wenn
die Sonne nicht scheint und der Wind
nicht weht Harbeck bezeichnete die
Einigung als politischen Durchbruch die
endgültige Genehmigung der Förderung
durch die Kommission steht allerdings
noch aus
der deutsche Rüstungskonzern Rheinmetall
hat mit dem Bau einer neuen Fabrik für
Teile des tarnkappenbombers F35 begonnen
wurden auch US-amerikanische Partner
beteiligt sind ab 2025 soll die
Produktion für mindestens 400
Kampflugzeuge beginnen und die Luftwaffe
und andere befreundete Nationen
auszurüsten ist so 400 Arbeitsplätze
sollen im 200 Millionen Euro teuren Berg
entstehen weitere 1.500 bei Zulieferern
nach anhaltenden heftigen Regenfällen
sind im Großraum Peking nach Angaben von
Staatsmedien mindestens 20 Menschen ums
Leben gekommen weitere werden noch
vermisst Videos zeigen wie Wasser und
Schlamm Straßenzüge im Westen der Stadt
verstopfen und weggespülte Autos im
Schlamm versinken rettungskräfte
brachten Anwohner die in den Fluten
eingeschlossen waren in Sicherheit von
den Überschwemmungen sollen eine halbe
Million Menschen betroffen sein
bei der Fußball-WM der Frauen konnten
die Engländerinnen auch das letzte
Vorrundenspiel für sich entscheiden sie
gewannen mit sechs zu eins gegen China
ebenfalls im Achtelfinale ist Dänemark
mit 2:0 gegen Haiti genauso wie die
Niederländerinnen mit einem klaren
sieben zu null gegen Vietnam spannend
wurde es dagegen für die Titel
Verteidigerinnen aus den USA im Spiel
gegen Portugal in der Nachspielzeit
verpassten die Portugiesinnen mit einem
Schuss gegen den Pfosten nur knapp ihre
Chance auf den Sieg und damit auf die
nächste Runde mit 0 zu 0 ziehen die
Amerikanerinnen damit ins Achtelfinale
ein
überfüllt verregnet und versunken im
Schlamm das war Woodstock 1969 die
Mutter aller Musikfestivals und seitdem
wissen wir wenn alles völlig aus dem
Ruder läuft kann es auch als Legende
enden
anhaltend schwierige Lage mit
Regenmengen von 40 Litern pro
Quadratmeter so ein Wetterbericht muss
nicht das Ende eines musikfests sein für
die 85.000 Fans die sich auf vier Heavy
Metal Tage in Wacken Schleswig-Holstein
freuen ist es zumindest ein enormes
Problem bei der Anreise Heike Kruse
jetzt über Kilometer lange Staus und was
man am besten daraus macht
Wacken ohne Matsch ist nicht Wacken wer
Heavy Metal Fan ist lieb much so ganz
grundsätzlich
in diesem Jahr gibt es jede Menge Matsch
vielleicht sogar ein bisschen zu viel
wegen Dauerregen sind alle campingwiesen
gesperrt die Veranstalter verkündeten
heute Abend den endgültigen anreisestop
aber alle die schon in Wacken sind
werden noch aufs Festivalgelände
geschleppt
viele standen seit gestern im endlos
Stau die ganz Harten Heavy Metal Fans
ließen sich nicht aufhalten und gingen
zu Fuß
andere feierten ihr eigenes kleines
Festival im Stau wir haben diese Insel
jetzt hier zu unserem Eigentum erklärt
letzter Arsch der Heide 23
und ich glaube wir bleiben hier
ne es gibt kein schlechtes Wetter es
gibt eine schlechte Getränke und die
haben wir nicht
knapp 20 Kilometer vor Wacken fanden
gestrandete Asyl auf dem Parkplatz eines
Baumarkts einige davon im
mustergartenhaus Modell Isa wir bekommen
hier gleich Strom rein die hat Dixi Klos
bestellt damit wir also hier die Zeit
überbrücken können das macht also echt
viel Spaß jetzt hier zu sein wir
versuchen das Beste daraus zu machen und
es gibt ja auch noch die Fans die es bis
aufs Festivalgelände geschafft haben
wir waren gestern neun Stunden in der
Schlange gestanden für 12 Minuten Radweg
aber wir sind wir haben es gepackt jetzt
immer wieder mal hier eine viel Regen
viel gute Laune ja Mädel Mädel Leute
noch ist das Festival nicht abgesagt
aber der Dauerregen soll zurückkommen
nach Wacken das heißt noch mehr Matsch
doch echte Heavy Metal Fans kann der
nicht stoppen
Deutschstunden in der Schlange und immer
noch gute Laune wir werden dabei bleiben
sagen jetzt aber erstmal danke für Ihr
Interesse ja wollen Ihnen außerdem noch
unser heute journal Update empfehlen
gegen 0.20 Uhr mit Christopher Wehrmann
von uns allen an sie einen angenehmer
[Musik]
guten Abend kaum ist das eine tief nach
Osten abgezogen kommt schon gleich das
nächste Tief hinterher das ist ein
Sturmtief Xan heißt es und es bringt
sehr viel Wind mit Morgen zunächst mal
in Frankreich und diese Tiefs die da
ankommen die dämpfen auch die
Temperaturen die liegen daher morgen im
westlichen Mitteleuropa nur so zwischen
19 und 23 Grad in Südeuropa wird es
dagegen wieder recht heißen bis zu 37
Grad die Temperaturen heute Nacht sinken
bei uns auf 16 Grad am Oberrhein und bis
10 Grad am alpenrad jetzt lässt der
Regen erstmal nach setzt aber in der
zweiten Nachthälfte hier im Westen
wieder ein und der breitet sich im Laufe
des Tages weiter ostwärts aus am
längsten freundlich ist es morgen hier
im Nordosten noch am Vormittag und auch
am alten Rand werden sie wohl den ganzen
Tag über die Sonne sehen kann am
Nachmittag entwickeln sich dann kräftige
Regenschauer und Gewitter hier im Westen
in Nordrhein-Westfalen in
Rheinland-Pfalz und in Hessen unternimmt
auch der Wind böig zu es könnte
stürmische oder sogar Sturmböen geben
die Temperaturen steigen auf 19 Grad in
der Mittelgebirgen und ganz im Norden
und bis 26 Grad an den Alpen und
wechselhaft geht es auch in den nächsten
Tagen weiter bei 16 bis 24 Grad und wenn
Sie sich jetzt fragen ob das immer so
weitergeht nein wie sie hier am Trend
für Freiburg im Breisgau sehen können
bis zum 10 August geht's dann aufwärts
in Sachen Temperatur und auch in Sachen
Sonnenschein guten Abend